today on the matt welsh show joe biden
makes the grotesquely absurd claim that
white supremacy
is the most lethal threat we face as a
country we'll analyze that claim and see
if we can't identify at least a few
other threats that are perhaps
a bit more urgent also five headlines
including the woke mob randomly deciding
that a certain actress is a racist clan
member it's not true but then again
this same actress supported blm prior to
this so i'm not sure i have much
sympathy for
and for a little change of pace the
republican congresswoman says that
someone came and sprayed offensive
graffiti on her property usually it's
people on the left
saying these things are happening to
them well the left is skeptical of the
claim for once i wonder why
they had a tennis star says that it's
too emotionally traumatizing
to speak to the media plus in our daily
cancellation we will cancel camila
harris again
well deserving once again all of that
and much more today on the matt walsh
[Music]
show
president joe biden now in the final
phase of his life has had several
significant conversion experiences
recently we we cannot quite call them
deathbed conversions but close enough
for one in the last few years he
discovered a belief in gender fluidity
though for seven decades or so he
operated under the firm assumption that
men are male and
women are female he now believes that
menstruation and pregnancy
should not preclude a person from being
considered a man
this is needless to say a seismic
ideological shift perhaps the most
massive flip-flop in political history
really
and yet he's never been asked to explain
it
in a change nearly as dramatic biden has
also
decided lately that america is
systemically racist now it's possible
that he always believed this but he
certainly didn't talk about it nearly as
much
back then as he does now the privileged
white male
biden has been in the system himself has
been one of the guys running the system
actually
for these past four or five decades then
he answered the 2020 primaries even
though there were several women and
people of color already in the contest
by winning the primaries he
intentionally prevented
all of those marginalized people from
having their shot at the presidency
he did all this while believing that
america is
is a systemically racist hell hole where
white supremacists prowl the streets and
black people are regularly murdered by
law enforcement simply for existing or
else he only arrived at that conclusion
after he'd already knocked out all of
his minority competitors whatever the
case
it's clear that biden has undergone a
remarkable evolution
at this late stage of his life or at
least is pretending
that he has and this evolution continued
on tuesday when biden visited tulsa
oklahoma to commemorate the 1921 tulsa
race massacre
during his prepared remarks biden took
time to bravely denounce the kkk
takes a lot of courage these days to
come out against the kkk but he did
now it's interesting to note that he
didn't say any of what you're about to
hear
when he was delivering the eulogy for
his good friend senator robert byrd who
was a former clan member and organizer
didn't say that then but he says it now
here it is
if my memory is correct there were 37
members of the house of representatives
who were open members of the clan
there were five if i'm not mistaken
could have been seven it was five
members of the united states senate open
members of the klan
multiple governors who were open
members of the klan
most people didn't realize that a
century ago the clan
was founded just six years before the
horrific destruction here in tulsa
and one of the reasons why it was
founded
was because of guys like me are catholic
it wasn't about african-americans that
it was about making sure that all those
polish
and irish and italian and eastern
european catholics who came to the
united states after world war one
would not pollute christianity
the flames from those burning crosses
towards every reason every region of the
country
millions of white americans belong to
the clan
and they weren't even embarrassed by it
they were proud of it
were there i i think were there people
in the audience shouting preach during
that did i hear that correctly it's an
odd time
yeah there were five senators who were
in the clan preach
amen what
now to further prove his wokeness biden
also invented his own demeaning racial
stereotypes and announced them as fact
hear this a lot from people on the left
they just they come up with with
stereotypes
i didn't even know existed for example
did you know that black business owners
don't have accountants
no i didn't either but that's what biden
claimed let's listen
that the data shows young black
entrepreneurs are just as capable of
succeeding given the chance
as white entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they
they don't have accountants but they
have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off
from the investments those people make
and i promise you that's why i set up
this
national small business administration
that's much broader
because they're going to get those loans
i i had what black business owners don't
have lawyers or accountants where are
you getting that from
but all this clumsy pandering i think
really pales in comparison to the claim
that biden made at another point in the
speech about the current threats
posed by white supremacists listen to
this
as i said in my address the joint
session of congress according to the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most
lethal threat to the homeland today not
isis not al qaeda white
supremacists some more
oddly timed we'll get to that claim in a
second but
why are you applauding yeah terrorism
for white supremacy
is a lethal threat yep what why is that
in a
why is that an applause line i don't
quite understand it well i really i'm
being facetious i do know
why people would applaud that because
that's what people want to believe
the most lethal threat to the homeland
now notice he doesn't say the most
lethal terror threat threats
there's no qualification he says it's
the most
lethal threat period he is correct at
least that we have heard
similar claims from the quote
intelligence community and certainly his
fellow democrats and backers in the
media echo this line or something close
to it
white supremacy is the boogeyman or
bigfoot
it's the monster that we're constantly
warned about that we rarely actually
see we're told that white supremacists
are lurking out there not just a threat
but the greatest threat we face yet each
day passes by
and all of the violence that uh the day
brings with it
has nothing to do with white supremacy
indeed the the majority of violent crime
in this country
isn't carried out by white people at all
let alone white supremacists
white people are vastly underrepresented
in the category of violent crime
especially among murderers
if white supremacists are the greatest
threat where are they
and what are they doing not much it
seems like
violence plagues our cities most of it
carried out by people who are not whites
and therefore presumably not white
supremacists
even the scourge of anti-asian violence
that we hear so much about is
predominantly an epidemic of racial
minorities
targeting another racial minority
i mean you've seen the videos maybe it's
not a coincidence almost
every single video we've seen
of an asian person being randomly
assaulted in the street
it is a non-white person carrying out
the assault
so where are the white supremacists
i mean it's just staying on the the
anti-asian thing for a second there's
an epidemic of anti-asian uh
assaults whites they're there are
according to biden there are white
supremacists everywhere they're the
greatest threat
why aren't they doing any of this
why aren't they responsible for any of
it
people are killed every day in this
country hundreds every week
most of them in blue cities most of them
at the hands of racial minorities yet
white supremacists are the most lethal
threats something is not adding up here
it's like showing up
to the site of a shipwreck and people
are drowning all around you
and you declare that the most lethal
threat they all face is uh
high cholesterol the claim doesn't
become much more intelligible even if we
limit it specifically to terror threats
biden did not limit it to terror threats
but let's just pretend for a moment
that we are talking about terror threats
black lives matter and antifa
inflicted two billion dollars of damage
to our cities in one summer
dozens of people were killed hundreds of
businesses and lives destroyed
and the long-term effects have proven
even more devastating crime has spiked
across the country as police
leave the force departments are defunded
all because of the threats made and
carried out
by black supremacist radicals and their
allies
black supremacy and left-wing militancy
is
far and away the greatest domestic
terror threat our nation faces
but all of this bloodshed and chaos
doesn't count in joe biden's estimation
because our government has decided not
to classify antifa and blm
as terrorist organizations it's as
simple as that
well they're not a terror threat if we
don't call them terrorists
they've decided not to even classify
their violence
as violence most of the time all of this
gets put in the
protest folder and then placed in the
filing cabinet and the drawer is shut
and locked
while swat teams are sent to chase down
old ladies who trespassed in the capital
on january 6th that's how biden and
company are able to
look at a country beset by violence
and blame it on people who aren't
actually committing hardly
any of it they do it by
intentionally miscategorizing much of it
and ignoring much more of it and simply
lying about the rest of it
and they also do it perhaps most
crucially by broadening the definition
of
white supremacy so that it's now come to
mean all bad things that happen
now every bad thing is somehow in some
way
the result of white supremacy even if
almost none of it
actually is now let's get to our five
headlines
all right uh i did want to mention one
thing one
one note you know i'm always screaming
at
at uh people who watch on youtube that
you need to leave a comment for the sake
of the algorithm
screaming and demanding and it's proven
pretty effective i have to say
this is why i'm uh i'm a theocratic
fascist it really is an effective method
you don't ask you demand i'm not going
to scream
this time because i think the the itunes
crowd they're a little bit more
sensitive but um
on itunes if you want to support the
show one of the best things you can do
is leave a review of the show make sure
it's five stars and say only nice things
um and then of course share the show
with all of your friends and neighbors
and
and uh and everyone else all right now
well i think we'll start here ron
desantis
we'll start with something positive i
try to do that on occasion
ron desantis he passed a bill um
yesterday or rather
signed a bill yesterday in florida
banning
now the media headlines are going to
tell you that he
banned um trans people or rather maybe
trans women from
playing in sports that's what the media
headlines will say and are saying
um but that's not correct it's not even
correct to say
and this is probably the most common
framing you'll see from the media
that ron desantis signed a bill
banning trans women from competing in
female sports
that's also not correct
the bill simply says that only
females can compete on women's teams
and males on men's teams that's all it
says
it's got nothing to do with whether
you're trans or not you can identify as
trans you can identify as
as whatever you want whatever you want
to do whoever you want to be
select the letter in the lgbtq
um acronym and uh doesn't matter that's
fine
it has no bearing on what team you're
playing on
the female teams are for are for females
the male teams are for males
that's it everybody gets the same rule
is under the same law this is equality
under the law
now the left is uh upset i mean they're
always upset no matter
whenever ronda santos does anything
they're always going to be upset when a
law like this is passed but he did it on
june 1st
which you you may know especially if you
listened to the show yesterday june 1st
the beginning of pride month
and they said that this is this is a
desecration of pride month how could he
do it on june 1st of all times now
i've heard some conservatives defending
it by saying oh come on he didn't
there wasn't he didn't do it on june 1st
on purpose it was he wasn't trying to
make any statement it's just this is
this is when it worked and
um why shouldn't he sign it during pride
month that may be the case
i now i don't want to this is just my
theory
i tend to think or maybe i hope at least
that he did it at the beginning of pride
month on purpose
and that makes it all the better that
makes it so much better
if he did it on purpose yeah because
that's exactly what i would do
if i was governor um
also ron santos was uh interviewed by i
think this is the federalist
and he had something to say that you
know you you probably hear a lot you
certainly hear a lot on daily wire shows
and among
some other conservatives we don't hear
this kind of thing from republican
politicians very often especially
prominent ones
but we did hear it from desantis here's
what he has to say
some of these battles of what the left
is doing and and woke-ism
you know it's effectively cultural
marxism and so
you can have theoretically a successful
um economy but if the underpinnings of
the culture
are just being torn apart i don't think
that that's a society that's going to be
very uh very successful over the long
term
very simple observation obviously
correct you can't abandon the culture
you can't give up on the culture and
then move over to
some other issue economics
and think that you're going to make any
serious impact there
yeah taxes economics these kinds of
things they're they're important
this is but it's not what moves people
it's not what motivates people
and it's not the most important thing
simple observation simple truth this is
something that by the way
the left realizes democrats realize this
you don't have to tell them twice
this is why for them they have been
heavily invested in the culture war
there's no they don't have to have an
argument about it you've ever
noticed that only among conservatives
and republicans do we have to even argue
about whether we should be participating
in the culture war to begin with
on the left there's no argument it is
fully understood that
obviously this is the most important
thing
you win the culture and you get
everything
politics comes with it
but among uh on the right we actually
have to to to make this argument and
ronda stanton is making it which is why
ron desantis i think is the um in terms
of
personal leaders he's has to be the
future of the republican party
donald trump if he cares about the
movement
he would support ron desantis come out
and endorse ron desantis
that would be the move if he cares about
the movement
not running himself as a 78 year old man
in 2024
and putting someone like ron desantis on
the back burner
all right uh moving on to this this is
from the daily wire it says
ellie kemper best known as aaron hannon
on the office is she best known as that
what was the other show that she's on
another show too
i have no idea um she came under fire
monday afternoon after a twitter user
revealed that she was once crowned
the queen of love and beauty at a
long-running missouri debutant ball
the user's incorrect claim that the
event is put on by the kkk
quickly spread resulting in dozens of
headlines that are likely to damage the
actress's career
now known as the fair saint louis local
business leaders established the
the veiled profit ball in veiled profit
ball okay
in 1878 to help the city compete with
chicago's rapidly expanding commercial
dominance
and has a pr effort against striking
workers inspired by i'm confused i don't
know are you confused too
inspired by the irish poem laila rook
by thomas moore and the revelries of
mardi gras the
group invented a mythic society centered
around a character known as the veiled
prophet of karasan
a mystic traveler who would select the
worthiest beauty from among the
daughters of the city's elite
kemper would have been an obvious
candidate before becoming an actress and
starring in shows like the unbreakable
kimmy schmidt that's the the show okay i
couldn't
remember and films like bridesmaids
kemper grew up in one of the wealthiest
families in missouri
uh so on and so forth anyway okay so she
was
back in 1999 and she would have been how
old was she then
i don't know i i presumably she was like
19 or 20 18 19 20 something like that
back then she was involved in this ball
it sounds super weird i think we can
agree this is like a this is a weird
thing
but the point is there's no evidence
at all that it has anything to do with
the kkk
or that there's anything explicitly
racist or
or implicitly racist about any of it
um and
it was just decided though by people on
the left
and by the woke mob on twitter and
social media that this was a kkk ball
it's not they just they took this thing
and they decided well it involves white
people
and it's kind of weird and they're rich
so that's basically the kkk
it's it's effectively a white
supremacist event even if it isn't
like we talked about in the opening
monologue that's that's how they get
away with saying things like white
supremacists are the greatest threat we
face
because everything is white supremacy
um and they decided this and now they're
gonna destroy her career randomly
they're gonna destroy her career on the
charge that she was in the kkk
this is like a 40 year old hollywood
actress
in the year 2021 and now
her her career is on the brink of
ruination
on completely invented charges that she
was
in the kkk or involved with it somehow
it's completely insane and and horrible
and
evil to do this to someone to destroy
them
on lies and uh and innuendo
so all of that is the case but on the
other hand
i really have no interest in defending
her i have no appetite for that
because this is also someone it won't no
big surprise here because she is a
hollywood actress in the year 2021.
uh so no surprise that she's someone
who's come out in support of of
blm you know she sent i think was on
instagram a few months ago
or it might have been last summer she
she put up a post about blm said she was
donating to the aclu to you know help
bring about
racial justice because that's the best
way to bring about racial justice is to
donate to the aclu
and she did that you know she she
offered her sacrifice to the altar of
blm
and now they're turning around and are
destroying her for for no reason
except i say no reason i mean the real
reason is that she's white
that that's the real reason
and the woke mob if if you're
a white person it doesn't really matter
what side you're on
if you're a white person they will they
will take any opportunity they can
to ruin you and there's really
it's almost as though there's nothing
personal about it it's just you're a
white person you're rich
you're quote unquote privileged if
they're given an opening
to take you down they'll take it
and um and of course this in spite of
that and this is the point this in spite
of the fact that many members of that
woke mob are also white
but they take part in this they feed the
beast until it turns around on them
and uh that's sort of what's happening
with ellie kemper here which is why
what what they're doing is wrong it's
based on a lie but at the same time
do i have a lot of sympathy no left wing
hollywood actress
offering your sacrifices to the blm
alter and now
you're being consumed
i don't you know i don't enjoy watching
it this kind of thing play out
you know it's kind of like if someone's
doing a youtube stunt with with live
fireworks and they blow off their hands
in the process
i don't i don't enjoy watching that i
don't enjoy the prospect of someone
being maimed do i do i feel really sorry
for them not really
can i say oh they don't they didn't
deserve for this to happen
well i can't say that i think they kind
of did deserve it
given that they were literally playing
with fire
but still i don't enjoy it but it's what
happens
maybe eventually people will start to
learn their lesson
you know you can you can you can say all
these things you can support blm
you can uh you can follow the script you
can follow the choreography
you can bend the knee literally it's not
going to do anything for you
it won't matter if they get a chance
to destroy you they'll take it
all right next here this is uh nancy
mace she's a republican congresswoman in
south carolina she says that her house
was vandalized
overnight this was a couple of nights
ago by antifa
and she she uploaded a video this is
kind of interesting because
we hear about these cases all the time
someone on social media saying oh look
at this
hateful graffiti someone has left on my
property and most of the time it's
someone on the left making this
claim and what happens lebron james
being one of them although although the
interesting thing there is he never did
a video
he never actually showed us we never
even saw the graffiti
and then he called he he he called or
someone at his property called the cops
and by the time by the time the cops had
showed up he had already someone had
already painted over the graffiti oh
okay
because that's what you would do but
whether there's video or not whenever
someone on the left
claims that there was the victim of some
kind of hate crime there was graffiti
or there was a racist note or a hateful
note left for them at their front door
or
uh or on their car windshield or
whatever
everyone on the left immediately
believes it unquestioning
yet for some reason people on the left
were a little bit skeptical
of this let's first of all let's watch
let's watch the video here it is
woke up this morning uh to my house
being vandalized last night
um you can see they spray-painted in
black past the pro-act
on the front of my house that's my bike
that one of the kids was using
last night shortly before
the house got vandalized it's very scary
they also spray painted no gods
no masters all politicians are bastards
with antifa
markings on it and you can see right in
front of my house and on the sidewalks
and the street out here you can see
where they spray painted cute nancy
um and then they've got antifa symbols
down
with uh some of the other you know
what's what pisses me off is uh makes me
so angry
is that this is a house that i live in
with my kids
my two kids and one of them was on the
bike last night
coming in from the movies and they're
not even
my kids aren't even safe on the front
porch of their own home
um and uh it's wrong we can disagree
politically but
vandalizing somebody else's property um
is wrong and is illegal so we are doing
everything we can
and i thank our police local police who
were here this morning
um alerting me to what was going on um
and want to thank them for their
diligence and figuring out
who did this okay so there it is
now as i said you could go on twitter
and go to
uh go to her twitter account nancy
mace's
twitter account you can see where she
originally posted these videos and then
you can look at the
uh the comments underneath and it's like
90
from people on the left including
verified account more accounts more
prominent people
outright accusing her of doing this
herself and saying this is a hoax
and we know of course that if she was on
the left
they would immediately accept it right
away
because they always do they
from from uh from bubba wallace to
justice millet to lebron james and all
of the
the less the lesser-known people who've
done their own hoaxes
on the left they accept all of that
right away so all you have to do is give
her
um different politics and also
preferably a different
different skin color and they would
accept that right away
no question no skepticism and in fact
they would say if you are skeptical of
it
then you're racist or you're sexist and
you should believe women and
this is what happens anytime a woman is
victimized she tries to
talk about it she's always doubted by by
privileged men and so
that that would be the line right but
here in this
one case all of a sudden they've
discovered skepticism
so we knew that was going to happen
now looking at the case though
objectively
i will say now i have no idea whether
this is legitimate or not i don't know
anything about
nancy mace i'm not making any
accusations i don't know
i i will say first of all that in
in all cases like this where someone is
reporting that there's been graffiti or
a note left or something like that
there should always be skepticism until
proof is offered
and that's that's a good general policy
with all things to have skepticism until
some sort of evidence or
until you're given a real reason to
believe it
there's no reason to believe it by
definition
um also it is i i will say and i did
notice when i was watching the video
it it it's a it's a it's a curious
that all of the graffiti is on concrete
surfaces
she has she has painted white surfaces
right there
and the the vandals apparently decided
only to to
to vandalize the concrete surfaces where
the stuff can be more easily washed off
and it's not a big deal right in terms
of damages
and you would just think if you're a
vandal and you're doing this
and there's a there's nice painted white
surfaces
and you hate this person you're trying
to vandalize their home
you'd think you'd probably spray paint
on those surfaces
i don't know so the fact that they only
chose the concrete services is a little
strange but on the other hand
what what gives it credibility is that
number one she called the police right
away
and many times you find in these hoaxes
the the people who are supposedly
victims
are strangely strangely reluctant to get
the police involved
so she called the police right away also
there have to be security cameras
all over that neighborhood you know this
is a wealthy neighborhood
there has to be security cameras
presumably on her house and if not on
her house then all over the neighborhood
be very easy to check you would assume
she knows that
and also she's a politician it's kind of
hard to imagine
a politician doing this as a hoax
quite a political risk it's also
dishonest and we know that's not going
to stop any from politicians from doing
it but
and then i'll say this too uh
this hoaxes of this kind
it's almost always people on the left
doing it
so yes the fact that she's on the right
does grant her a little bit more of the
benefit of the doubt
because this is not this is not common
behavior on the right on the left
this is just what they do it's it's a
common tactic
so we'll see police are involved they'll
look at the
security camera footage and uh i think
we'll know we'll know the truth
pretty quickly the other thing is you
know when it's someone on the left and
they perpetrate a hoax
and the cops discover that it's a hoax a
lot of times they don't really tell us
that
there was a case of althea bernstein and
i think that was in milwaukee i believe
and she remember she was the one who was
at a said she was a stoplight and some
racist white guys came up and set her on
fire
and there of course there's security
cameras all over the place red light
cameras everything she said it happened
in the middle of a city
and um the cops would have figured out
almost right away that it was a hoax but
they didn't really tell us that or it
took him a while to
and even then they didn't say it was a
hoax they just said oh we never found
any evidence of this
in this case if it's a hoax i think that
there will be no hesitation to let us
know
so we will see all right i will also
play this for you
mara gay from the new york times was on
msnbc
and uh she blasted
white americans for she says being so
good at
forgetting history this is something
that white americans do we forget
history
um here she is let's listen of course
then you look at what happened in tulsa
and we have images today of hundreds of
world war one
black veterans from world war one being
rounded up
and put into uh the equivalent of local
you know
uh concentration camps and many of them
lynched it's a very harsh difficult
history that really is
i think still prescient today when you
think about we still have survivors
from this you know the other reason this
is an important story
is because i think americans especially
white americans but americans in general
tend to be very good at forgetting
history but also
tend to think that slavery was a very
long time ago and that discrimination
was a very long time ago
the reality is is not that's just not
the case
yeah it's it's um
no it's not about forgetting history
and this by the way of course is a
racist
thing to say this she's a black woman
making this accusation about white
white americans in general you know
white americans always forgetting
history obviously race is reversed and
all that
she would be she would never be allowed
on tv again if she said so if you can
imagine a white
uh a white person on fox news a white
woman on fox news saying you know black
americans they're they're really good at
forgetting history
never be allowed on tv again after
saying that
but taking races out of it um
now i i think there is a problem in
america of americans
being ignorant of history in general
and that's a that is a a a function
of the school system and of academia
it's not about people forgetting history
now that's not the issue
you go up to an average college student
and you ask them
you know in in which decade
was the was world war ii fought
um the fact that a lot of them won't be
able to answer it it's not because
they've forgotten the information it's
just that they're ignorant of it because
we don't really teach
american history in schools anymore
but as for the atrocities and horrible
things that have happened in american
history
um no it's not a matter of forgetting it
no it's just we we acknowledge
that horrible things happened a lot of
horrible things
in american history and in world history
but then also we we have to keep living
our lives in the present
so that's the point slavery
okay most americans are again generally
speaking very ignorant of history and
that's the fault of the school system
but everyone knows that slavery happened
we hear quite a lot about that everyone
knows that
we're not no no one is no one's
forgetting that
and yet you continue along living your
life
because it was a bad thing that happened
in history but now we're living here in
the present day
and so you have to to live in that
moment and keep moving forward
that's the point
at what point i guess when we're when
we're constantly lectured as white
americans
for supposedly forgetting all of the
terrible things that white people have
done in the past
as as if there's not enough emphasis on
that really
it is when we talk about american
history it's the main thing we emphasize
now
it's at the point where it's like the
only thing we're allowed to emphasize if
we're talking about american history
are the bad things that white people did
i guess what i would ask mara gay and um
anyone in her camp is at what point is
it
enough acknowledgement will there ever
be a point when you would say
okay it's been acknowledged
now we can continue living along in the
present day
is there ever a point where that will
happen for you
i'm guessing your answer is probably no
all right let's move on to now uh
reading the youtube comments
this is from dave in fact i got a few a
few comments like this that kind of blew
my mind
um we were talking about blues clues
yesterday and how it's now become
a platform for lgbt indoctrination david
says
blue is a girl dog matt i didn't know
either until my kid told me but is that
true blue is supposed to be a girl dog
so maybe they're you know i that that to
me surprises me maybe there was a little
bit of gender fluidity going on in
blue's clues even from the very
beginning
um billy the pilot says matt the next
time someone says tying your shoes huh
you should respond
striking up awkward conversations huh
the key to stopping the madness may be
to make it worse it's the darkest
just before the dawn i can see that but
with all small talk exchanges
that is a clever response but with all
small talk exchanges my
goal is just to get out of it as quickly
as possible
so i don't want to say anything that
would that might extend it or might
uh precipitate a response
that's why my answer is always yep
mm-hmm
like if someone walks in and says hey
it's really raining out there yep
that's it that's my goal just to get out
of it
uh charlie says matt please read this on
the show it's my life's work for you to
read my comment
well there you go charlie what are you
going to do with your life now
your one goal i i actually feel bad now
because i've taken from you your one
goal this this thing that has animated
your life for so long
and now you have to find a way to keep
living
uh another comment says matt you're
wrong you aren't anti-social you're
selectively social
i i i kind of like that i like that
that's that's a good way of putting it
pete says the best sequel movie is star
wars the empire strikes back
um i don't think i've ever seen that
entire i'm not sure i've ever seen
any of the uh any of the original star
wars movies all the way through
because i find them so boring and
tedious i can't get through the entire
thing
but no the best sequel of all time is
godfather uh part two which is also the
best movie period of all time
and there's really no discussion to be
had about that and a chunky monkey good
username says
so nickelodeon bans one of their best
spongebob episodes
titled midlife crustacean because it's
not child friendly
but throws that garbage on blue's clues
yeah i don't know anything about that
and i'm not i'm not even sure if
spongebob is still
currently on the air i don't let my kids
watch it because i don't think it's
appropriate for kids
because it's vulgar and the thing is you
know when i was a kid and spongebob is a
little bit after my
after my time um but there were i can
remember there were there were cartoon
shows when i was a kid like
in the early 90s and mid 90s that
weren't appropriate
for for younger kids because they were
kind of vulgar
and weird like ren and stimpy for
example
but you you knew that that's what those
shows were
and so a lot of parents won't let their
kids watch them
now you're they're they're taking these
totally innocuous
shows for preschoolers
and it's and injecting these sort of
things into those into those shows so
it's a really kind of a different ball
game
and finally jared says matt you finally
got a camera b angle
and it only took you 655 shows
congratulations well thank you we do
have a new
uh camera angle on the show exciting
you know went from one camera in my car
screaming into it yeah it took us 655
shows now we've got a second
655 more shows maybe they'll be a third
you never know things get pretty crazy
around here
i know there are a lot of small business
owners and even large business owners
who listen to this
show and one thing i'm pretty sure i
don't want to speak for you but
i think you probably didn't get into
entrepreneurship
and and the business world in order to
deal with hr issues it probably wasn't
your
the the thing that really drove you i
don't know i could be wrong
if it's not that's why you need to look
into a band b
um bambi you know if you didn't start
your business in order to worry about hr
compliance bambi can take care of that
for you hr manager salaries aren't cheap
an average of
seventy thousand dollars a year on top
of all the difficulty that comes with it
bam b spelled b a m b e was created
specifically for small businesses
to solve this problem you get a
dedicated hr manager based in the united
states who will craft hr policy maintain
your compliance all for just 99
a month while the average salary for an
hr manager is 70
000 a year you don't have to worry about
that here
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email real time chat
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
so you've got to look into this go to
bambi.com walsh right now
to schedule your free hr audit that's
bambi.com
walsh spelled b-a-m-b-e-e dot com
walsh you know if americans love
anything i think uh
it's their freedom or at least i hope
most americans do anyway
and it feels like there are some
powerful forces trying to take that from
you
because they are they're out there all
the time but you shouldn't and don't
have to let them do it just pick up ben
shapiro's latest book the authoritarian
moment for tips on how to stop
this insane power grab so don't wait arm
yourself with the knowledge that you
need so that the woke
cult if they come for you you're going
to know how to shut them down
pre-order the authoritarian moment now
at amazon barnes noble or any other
major bookseller now let's get to our
daily cancellation so today we have
another exciting opportunity to cancel
camila
harris harris was interviewed on msnbc
for their 50 over 50 list which
apparently is a list
honoring women over the age of 50. msnbc
says that women over 50 are quote
having a moment i'm not sure what that
means exactly it might have something to
do with menopause
i won't ask any questions in any case
camilla harris is over 50 and she
identifies as a woman
and so she was interviewed and here's
how that interview went
what's your advice to women in their 20s
and 30s who feel like they have to pack
it all in who are stressed who are like
feel like there's a clock ticking and
that there's like a
time shelf on their life sorry can i i
just want to jump in here i
and i know women love it when men
interrupt so please allow me to
intercept this question
what would i say to women who feel like
the clock is ticking and there's a time
limit on their life well i would say
yes you're you're right about that
you're correct the clock is ticking
you'll be dead sooner than later
even if you live a comparatively long
life it's still only a matter of a few
decades
you can think back now to when you were
a young child and it doesn't even feel
that long ago
because it wasn't and soon you'll be old
and dying in a hospital bed thinking
back to this moment right now and it
won't feel all that long ago because it
isn't or else you'll die before you're
old maybe tomorrow or today or
you don't know maybe you'll get into a
car accident this weekend who knows
there is a time limit there's the point
that the clock is ticking you are
in the process of dying right now every
day you march closer to your own demise
every step you take takes you closer to
the abyss
and you should live with that knowledge
live with that presence of mind the last
thing you should do
is convince yourself that you'll live
forever
don't try to pretend that your sense of
impending doom
is some sort of illusion don't wave it
away and say oh no i'm i'm being
ridiculous
no it is not an illusion it's real
that's what i would say but something
tells me camilla harris
probably won't say that one
continue with your ambition and don't be
don't apologize for it
and continue to believe that you
can do whatever you want to do
but also know you have a right to expect
things like affordable child care you
have a right to expect
paid family leave when you need to take
care of your children
or your elderly parents that you have a
right to resp
to expect that you will be seen in the
full dimension of who you are
and your responsibilities and that they
should be supported
these things can co-exist so what i say
then do not accept false choices
that you have to choose either this
thing or that thing
that's a false choice don't accept it
all right yeah the one thing i i love
about camille harris is that
she has this thing that she does where
she'll
she'll say some banal pointless
platitude but then she kind of leans in
and raises her eyebrows in a way that
it's like she's you're supposed to be
impressed with this insight where she'll
she'll say
what would i say i would say believe in
yourself
pretty good stuff hear what i just said
believe in yourself never heard that
before
she says continue to believe that you
can do whatever you want to do but also
know you have a right to expect things
like affordable child care and paid
family leave
and that you'll be seen in the full
dimension of who you are that's what
that was her answer
no i hate to say it but i think my
answer was a lot better this is why the
world needs more
mansplaining i think what we just heard
there from camille harris was it was a
mind-numbing
mixture of falsehoods cliches and vapid
babbling
but we'll try our best to break it all
down she says that you should continue
to believe that you can do whatever you
want to do
no you you should not continue believing
that it's better if you never start
believing that
you in fact cannot do whatever you want
to do it's probably true to say that the
average person can't do almost any of
the things they want to do
or at least we could say that that what
you want
and what is real will almost never line
up
perfectly because reality asserts itself
over
our fantasies reality reality doesn't
care what we want
it just is and it goes goes on being
what it is no matter how much we wish it
away
so one of the best things we can do is
learn to accept
reality on its own terms it's better to
think
less about what we want i'm not saying
that we should never think about
what we want or that we shouldn't want
anything what i'm saying is that
we especi all of us especially in modern
society
we spend far too much too much time
thinking
about what we want and then experiencing
the constant parade
of disappointment when what we want
fails to line up with what is
so maybe some of the energy spent on
focusing on our wants
could instead be used to contemplate
different questions rather than
what do i want how about what is right
what's good what's healthy what's
feasible
what's practical we know about our wants
now let's move on and think about some
of those other questions which are also
very important
as for this idea that we have a right to
expect
harris says we or women anyway have a
right to expect
paid family leave and affordable child
care and to be seen in the full
dimension of who they are i'm not sure
what that last bit means
it doesn't mean anything really harris
was just filling space babbling
incoherently
she reminded me of of myself when i was
trying to hit a word count in a book
report in seventh grade
but i hadn't actually read the book in
question so you're just filling in words
like um
and in conclusion the great gatsby was
trying to be seen in the full dimension
of
who he is yeah that sounds like that
means something
and by the way i'm miming their writing
with an actual pencil
kids that's what we used to do back in
the dark ages
paid family leave and affordable
childcare on the other hand are at least
intelligible concepts but
what does it mean that you have a right
to expect them
putting aside the question of whether
these are good policies how can you have
a right
to expect them well in a certain way you
do have a right to expect
them or anything else you can expect
whatever you want to expect you have a
right in the sense that
nobody can stop you from having
expectations so go ahead and expect
that doesn't mean you have a right to
have all of your expectations met
your expectations are simply your
desired reality it's the version of the
world that you have concocted in your
head
and you hope that the actual world lines
up with it but as already covered the
actual world never does
not perfectly and often not at all so so
where does this supposed right get you
where do your expectations get you again
it's not that you should have no
expectations
it's just a matter of focus should you
be focused all the time
on your expectations on your wants on
your desires
or should you get down to the business
of living and doing and making and
building and striving and sweating and
all of that now to take the latter
course
you have to let go of your stranglehold
on your desires
and dive down into the muck and grime of
the real world it's kind of like going
from
a warm bath to the ocean the ocean is
colder and darker and scarier and more
volatile
but it's more magnificent it's more
incredible there's more potential
there's more to do there's more to see
there's more to achieve
you have to choose between those two you
have to choose between your fantasies
and reality you can't live
in your fantasies and in reality at the
same time you have to decide
which will be your focus now camille
harris and people like her
they want you to live entirely in your
head in your desires you notice that
her whole answer was all about things
you should feel and think
it had nothing to do with with doing
anything
they want you to inoculate yourself from
reality
they want you to wait around for your
expectations to be filled and everything
you want to magically materialize
they want you to live passively to live
wanting to live expecting
they want you to waste your life
basically
and that is why they and she are
canceled
whether they were expecting it or not
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha thomachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show dr anthony fauci's
emails emerge and they are not
particularly flattering plus president
biden unleashes a tirade against america
to commemorate the 100 year anniversary
of the tulsa massacre that's today on
the ben shapiro show give it a listen
you